[Musica]
anni jones bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono dj ed oggi
siamo tornati sull'episodio di just è
detto ormai visto tutti ragazzi cosa si
prova a veder ballare un deficiente ma
l'altro giorno mi sono chiesto ma se i
deficienti a ballare fossero quattro che
cosa mica succederebbe scopriamolo
l'ex grosso a guardare la fertile di
fare lista scenari mai primo marito né
isolare questa scena mi hai fatto
sbagliata se rai per terra e file a
[ __ ] ci sei anche in perfect io sono
berna anni da beppe sto facendo niente
non ci sei
[Musica]
a metà per mete non sto facendo niente
terzi 6 caricati
[Musica]
noi cosa pc franchezza non albatros
si cercano gli esce ma come cazzo fatto
noi molto che la fa mercato è sbarcato
la principessa sissi si presterà ad
amici la faccia così ti voglio io la
sera carico in discoteca rimorchiati
al minimo lo sta facendo
grazie ragazzi per non altro pensa di
essere sui un po ha sbagliato torno a
sito del ciclo e non siamo i poveri e
gli organi siamo insomma possa fare c'è
in mali non c'è più
dobbiamo toccare la minchia colpi
diritti
[Musica]
non state facendo
sì perché la gente vedere sembra che
ballare finalità alle feste ma da questi
quanto sopra vi invitiamo il barca c'è
scritto che perché fate talmente cagare
che voglio suicidarmi necessaria per
qualcosa
barber back door ma cos'è sta roba
ma noi tu sei qui c'è uno che non cessa
un cinico ma tutti beppe una cosa
possibile
ma si sa piace ma non ci credo
quest'anno si è fatto io sono i due
persone così c'è chi siede dietro a dire
la tristezza di persona e dopo questo
punto dichiara guerra a chi è che siamo
tutti uguali po tutti tutti a rega
scommettete che mi questo
[Musica]
chi riesce a farmi avanti solo così tra
giuro che fa meno di nichi un genio
legami fa meno di nichi un genio lega
grazie di chi si sta ingrandendo viola
ci sta dietro questo conferma la miseria
se fate consentito di aiuto coltivano
quindi mi stai prendendo spesso carente
adesso chissà come mai superato
ma dai oddio ma se veramente fermi conto
mi ha fatto hai vinto tu ti fa meno di
nichi un genio legate assieme a lei fa
tutto tenere i piedi per istituto drive
in un ciclo di possibili questo ha fatto
46 c'è tutta seduto per prime in pieno
rai abbiamo sbagliato neanche per tirare
dieci minuti di video cosa sono vissuti
ha tentato di vedere nei play ma
[Musica]
guardate che sono stato nettamente
superato in volata ma nettamente sapete
contare a chi attende ancora che sono
quelli degli uccelli ma non era la vedo
casale cello vero che le sue cazzate
anni passati a chiunque sia l'azzurra ha
vinto a poter esigere ricompattarci 2
castellana
abbiamo scoperto il suo talento ragazzi
questa è stata la performance cosa mi è
piaciuto al momento in piazza capace di
facebook come ritornare schizzare salsa
vestiti si sa che lì ci vediamo al
prossimo video non ho telecomando da
ragazzi